[Aplausos]
la transacción tuvo lugar en plena calle
a la vista de todos este cachorro acaba
de ser enviado desde polonia
un pequeño pastor alemán que como muchos
otros fue importado ilegalmente a
alemania
stefan clips hizo su pedido por internet
solo unas horas antes unos pocos clics y
se encuentra con este anuncio que
promete un pastor alemán de tres meses
por mil euros esto supone la mitad de la
cantidad de un criadero certificado este
es el que vamos a recibir hoy en la foto
es un animal precioso este activista de
los derechos de los animales empezó a
perseguir a los traficantes de mascotas
hace 10 años este tráfico se aceleró en
los años 2000 con la aparición de las
plataformas de venta por internet y
explotó durante la pandemia
cada semana se transportan 50.000
cachorros dentro de la unión europea
para venderlos en los países miembros no
se trata de un pequeño negocio de
cachorros sino de una auténtica mafia
muy bien organizada aquí alemania es por
desgracia el principal mercado de la
unión europea para estos cachorros
stefan clip se entiende regularmente
trampas a los traficantes operaciones
filmadas con cámara oculta es importante
reunir pruebas porque estos versos los
tramitan todo cuando llega la policía
ese día la novia de stefan clips thein
actúa como al suelo unos minutos después
una pareja joven llegó con el cachorro
en brazo
de llevant
mientras tanto stefan clips ten se ha
puesto en contacto con la policía el
joven dice no entender el alemán la
conversación continúa con el criador que
está en polonia
va en contra de la ley vender cachorros
en internet tan jóvenes y llevarlos al
otro lado de la frontera
los papeles del cachorro no están en
orden no está vacunado su salud deja
mucho que desear este perro tiene unos
dientes de leche muy pequeños tiene como
máximo 6 semanas pero nos lo vivieron
como un cachorro de 12 semanas este
cachorro no debe estar aquí debería
seguir con su madre pero no trabaja con
calefacción se necesitan aproximadamente
8 millones de cachorros al año para
satisfacer la demanda europea
muchos de ellos proceden de países de
europa del este como polonia en ausencia
de controles fronterizos se revenden en
países donde la demanda es alta
estos son los perros que hemos
recuperado recientemente de una perrera
inapropiada no lejos de la ciudad de
girls en su refugio de qufu gregor vio
lawes que acoge a perros que han
escapado del comercio un negocio que
genera más de mil millones de euros al
año en europa según las ong de derechos
de los animales hemos salvado a estos
animales del tráfico internacional
la asociación de gregor está autorizada
a intervenir en las explotaciones
polacas ilegales ya confiscar los
animales en peligro los animales se
hacinan en condiciones de cría
desastrosas a principios de este año
rescató estos perros destinados al
mercado alemán internamente en feria con
15 grados bajo cero a la intemperie y no
tienen hogar día y noche todo el año
desde 2012 la legislación polaca permite
a los particulares criar y comerciar con
animales de compañía esto puede hacerse
mediante la creación de una asociación
claro para este tráfico que es sinónimo
de sufrimiento animal cada año
conseguimos desmantelar una decena de
estas granjas de pícaros pero los demás
no tienen que preocuparse porque esta
gente sabe muy bien que el estado no
hace nada en la lucha contra el tráfico
de animales y sin embargo según los
grupos de defensa de los animales el 80
por ciento de los perros importados de
europa del este están enfermos o son
incapaces de adaptarse a la vida
familiar los perros son muy agresivos
por sus título está especialista en
psicología animal advierte a los
posibles compradores
estos animales tienen lesiones físicas
llagas problemas digestivos debido a la
mala alimentación la atención médica de
estos perros es muy costosa del ataque
y también nos encontramos en una
intervención en una granja en la que los
animales se reproducían entre sí con
todo lo que ello puede implicar en
términos de patología para los cachorros
como resultado muchos de ellos mueren
antes de llegar a la edad adulta para
frenar este tráfico los eurodiputados
apuestan por la futura legislación
europea sobre servicios digitales los
revendedores podrían estar obligados a
registrarse e identificarse en los
sitios de venta en línea esto afectaría
a los creadores comerciales pero también
a todos los vendedores privados que son
los que plantean un problema deberían
estar obligados a registrarse y las
plataformas deberían estar obligadas a
controlarlos
este es nuestro principal objetivo
porque al menos disuadiría a los demás
criminales
actualmente el negocio de los cachorros
es más lucrativo que nunca según la
organización mundial para el bienestar
de los animales 4 patas el precio de los
cachorros en internet se ha duplicado
desde el inicio de la pandemia una mina
de oro para los creadores sin escrúpulos